every monday this month we will be
having important conversations around
mental health because in case you don't
know may is mental health awareness
month just this morning the child mind
institute is launching its dare to share
campaign to encourage kids to talk about
the issue it features celebrities
artists athletes and role models who are
all sharing their personal stories to
destigmatize the debate take a look
i myself struggle with depression it's
something that i have to deal with every
day i've taken a lot of steps to try and
better my situation
i'm on medication for it and i just want
you to know that there is help and there
are resources out there for you i think
ultimately
just telling someone about it made me
feel better and i didn't even need any
big piles of wisdom just being able to
express myself
helped get the
overwhelming feelings out and they
stopped being quite so overwhelming i
will tell you from
uh being a very very afraid
7 8 13 23
31 and now 42 year old woman
uh
it does get better and there are
beautiful moments waiting for you
beautiful words jamie howard is a senior
clinical psychologist from the child
mind institute she joins us now and will
be with us nearly every monday this
month jamie good morning good morning
thanks for having me of course thank you
for joining us why is it important for
celebrities and individuals of influence
to share their stories it's so important
because one in five children and
adolescents has a diagnosable mental
health or learning disorder so these are
actually the most common disorders of
childhood but stigma is a huge barrier
to care so when we have celebrities who
we look up to and we admire and we know
that they're so successful and talented
that makes it seem like oh it would be
okay if i shared two i can get the help
that i need and when you say one in five
children do you have a specific age
range that you think parents you really
need to pay attention to this particular
age this particular phase this
particular sex yeah that's a good
question so we like we like to look at
through age 24 or so because that's when
the brain really kind of solidifies and
our frontal lobes stop developing and
we're adults at age 24. and we know that
the onset of mental health problems 50
of disorders starts before the age of
14. before 14 and 75 before the age of
24. so that's really what we want to
look at is that sort of childhood
through early adulthood what's happening
before age 14 that would cause you
mental anguish and stress i think it's a
complicated answer and it's something we
call a stress diathesis model which
basically means we have a biological
predisposition and we have the
environment we grow up in and if we're
sort of born prone to a mental health
disorder it's going to come out earlier
rather than later in life so everybody
wants to raise resilient kids right it's
a goal as a parent you don't want to
coddle your kids but it's hard to know
where the line is between telling a kid
to shake it off and get back in there
and it being a chronic problem a real
problem right so you want to monitor
it's okay for kids to have setbacks and
we want kids to have moments of failure
that builds character it builds
resilience so we don't want to spare
children from any disappointments
necessarily but we want a monitor to
make sure that they're functioning right
so if it goes on for say two weeks of a
child being consistently sad and down
and not interested in things they used
to enjoy then we might think oh this is
starting to seem like a depressive
episode and not just a momentary setback
something i had to learn as a parent was
each kid receives information
differently yeah so i have to parent
them differently i can't have the same
mental health conversation with my 18
year old as i do in my 16 year old as i
do with my daughter who's 12. um what
advice do you give to parents that might
be dealing with different personalities
and struggling with an approach to
talking to multiple kids yeah well so
some rules of thumb are that you want to
ask open-ended questions and you want to
be curious you don't necessarily want to
go in expecting you already know the
answer kids will always surprise you so
sort of state your observations and with
empathy and earnestness ask like so so
tell me what's going on i've noticed you
haven't been spending time with your
friends lately or i've noticed your
grades seem to be slipping and don't
jump to sort of reprimanding them but
say what's going on yeah what's going on
is such a nice way to say it what about
kids who are struggling and don't know
how to ask for help so parents who are
struggling and don't know how to ask for
help right
right well that's why it's so important
to have these ongoing conversations so
that the onus isn't necessarily on kids
to say hey i think i might be struggling
with a mental health problem they don't
necessarily have that language
especially when they're young but if you
have repeated conversations with
children starting when they're younger
then there's an opportunity so suicide
is obviously a worst case scenario but
it is a leading cause of death for for
kids 15 to 19. uh and we've heard from
other guests that it you should say the
word it's not it's okay to say to a
younger person you're not planning a
seed you're not planning a scene yeah is
that is that the right advice that's
true right so if someone is not suicidal
and you say to them hey have you been
thinking about killing yourself they
will they will not think oh no i wasn't
but now i am that's not how that works
it's only if you have a mental health
condition that you would say actually
yes and thank you for asking parents
should be frank about it they should be
frank there's nothing to be understood
do you think children would answer that
question honestly i think a lot of
children would because it feels really
bad to have depression or anxiety right
like we we want to feel better when we
have these conditions it's often we just
don't know how
and it's not a secret anymore and that's
part of breaking the stigma actually
yeah exactly jamie howard thank you very
much we'll see you again real soon we'll
be right back